[Music]
welcome everyone good afternoon thanks
for joining our session today this
session is cloud networking for the
hybrid enterprise my name is Zach Stiles
i'm here with my colleague matt new inna
Matt and I are both networking
specialists in the customer engineering
organization within Google cloud so we
work on a daily basis with customers
such as yourself to help kind of onboard
them understand networking within Google
cloud how to best take advantage of our
networking features and more specific to
this session how to best integrate with
your existing on-premise networking
environments we do have the Dory Q&A
enabled for this session so if you have
the next step you can click on Dory Q&A
and pop questions into the app we want
to make sure we have enough time for all
the content in the presentation so we're
not going to do live Q&A today but the
Dory is open through the end of the
month so through April 25th so if you
have questions during the session if you
have questions after the session or when
you get back home pop them into the app
Matt and I look forward to interfacing
with you online and we may even blog
about a few other questions we'll see
we'll see what happens
so a quick summary of what we're gonna
cover in the next 50 or so minutes I'm
gonna start out by talking about like
familiar networking concepts that
everyone's familiar with from your
on-premise networking environment and
how those map into the global cloud so
if you have kind of direct correlation
between things I'll make the connections
for you and I'll really highlight how
some of those things are different in
the cloud versus what you may be
familiar with in terms of your
on-premise network next I'm gonna hand
it over to Matt Matt's gonna talk about
some common enterprise designs and some
recommendations for how you can approach
those talking in a little bit more
detail about the features that I've
talked about how you actually leverage
those based on our recommendations and
then finally we're going to come back
together and we're going to talk about
some best practices so what we typically
recommend the customers as they start
their journey towards Google cloud all
right so let's jump right in again I'm
gonna start with kind of some like
common networking concepts and I'll map
those into what their equivalents are
inside of the Google cloud environment
this is the current state of Google's
global backbone network so we have our
own private backbone Network it's one of
the largest private backbone networks in
the world one of the unique benefits of
cloud networking is that within a few
minutes through configuration that you
define this basically becomes your
infrastructure so you can extend your
on-premise Network environment literally
across the globe based on which cloud
regions you deploy compute and other
workloads into and that's really the
premise of this presentation which is
how do you extend your on-premise
networking environment with things that
you're familiar with but do so in a way
that's scaleable manageable and
hopefully with this little design and
operational burden as possible so again
essentially this is basically your
backbone network completely under your
control let's start with some very
familiar kind of constructs though your
on-premise data center environment
undoubtedly is made up of physical
network devices these devices are
commonly purpose specific so whether
we're talking about a core switch or an
access switch or maybe a firewall
whether it's physical or virtual these
devices in your network are often put
together in a very specific topology
based on those capabilities and where
those devices are placed and how you
connect them is very relevant to how the
network performs and what capabilities
it has now datacenter topologies have
evolved over time you had your
traditional three-tier kind of core
distribution and access networks and you
have this resurgence recently of kind of
cloth based fabrics where you have spine
and leaf networks but generally speaking
in your on-premise networks the topology
at least the physical topology is
generally fairly static so it doesn't
change that much so we have the concept
here of the device we have the concept
of placement being very relevant
important in terms of what those
capabilities are and how they apply to
the things Europe you're actually
connecting to the network next we have
different capabilities for how you
virtualized that physical infrastructure
so for example you have virtual LANs or
VLANs that allow you to provide virtual
segmentation within your physical
topology you can even have isolation
from an IP forwarding perspective so for
example you can have VR F's virtual
routing and forwarding instances and
historically there's been some provider
specific implementations of these
capable
so for example maybe virtual data
centers or VDCs and various different
types of overlay and underlay
technologies the premise here is really
the same right how do i basically
virtualize and isolate different
capabilities on top of the same physical
infrastructure so here again we have the
virtualization concepts VLANs IP
forwarding domains like vrf sand
sometimes virtual data centers or VDCs
moving on we have what I refer to as
kind of network identity so when you
talk about how you identify systems
particularly from a network perspective
it's no surprise we start talking about
IP addressing and subnets that these
kind of exists pervasively everywhere
right there in the public internet there
in your private network they obviously
exist in the cloud but what I'm
specifically talking about in this
context is the importance of what an IP
address actually means about the
identity of a system like I know these
range of IP addresses are my database
servers or these range of IP addresses
are a DMZ where I want to kind of apply
a certain type of traffic controls and
placement is also important here right
oftentimes where something connects to
the network so it's a lot about what it
is and implies what types of access it
has or it will allow and much like
there's a low rate of change with
physical networks there's typically a
pretty low rate of change with the
number of subnets and VLANs and IP
addressing schemes that you configure in
your on-premise network I mean certainly
they change and expand over time but
they're generally not changing at a high
rate of volume on a daily or weekly
basis now if we've gotten this far and
you're thinking great sac IP addresses
in subnets I'm super happy I came to
your session just be patient please I
promise we're actually going to help you
think about these constructs in a
different way in the cloud that
hopefully makes your cloud journey a
little bit more simple from a networking
perspective next we have various
different types of traffic controls from
a data center perspective so you have
firewalls right these again can be
physical or virtual devices you have
network based access control lists you
may apply these at various points in the
network so these are more like very
network centric you create these based
on IP addresses sudden that's interfaces
etc sometimes you have host based
filtering through agents or other things
you actually install on the endpoints
and finally more recently you have kind
of like
an emergence of what I call drop by
default fabrics or networks where
multiple hosts are connected to the same
network and whereas they may have
historically been able to automatically
talk to each other if they could
discover each other that's no longer the
case these networks or fabrics actually
drop most unicast traffic by default
which requires that you must explicitly
configure what communication is allowed
across that network so I've got here a
set of controls for how I actually
identify and filter traffic so that's
where we kind of came from right we have
the devices we have the importance of
placement of those devices based on
their functionality we have the network
based virtualization technologies we
talked about VLANs we talked about V RFS
we talked about access control
capabilities and so now let's start to
map these into their equivalents inside
of Google cloud so the first one is
really the device what does a device
mean what is the equivalent of your
on-premise network switch in the Google
cloud environment and there really isn't
one so this is funny for the first one
there's really not a direct equivalent
and this is really a byproduct of the
fact that most everything inside of the
Google cloud environment is heavily
software driven and globally distributed
so there's really no equivalent do I
have this network switching device what
is its equivalent in the cloud it just
doesn't exist now that being said we do
actually surface some capabilities adds
devices this is primarily from a
configuration management perspective so
for example when you're setting up
routing between your network and the
Google Cloud Network you can figure that
routing using something called cloud
router now cloud router is presented to
you as a thing you configure but it's
not actually a device behind the scenes
it's actually a distributed set of
software processes that live within a
particular cloud region so you're not
actually configuring a device you're
basically providing a configuration that
we then program these software processes
with and distribute them across the
infrastructure in a similar fashion you
have the VPC firewall the native
firewall built into the virtual private
cloud in Google Cloud we present this to
you from a configuration perspective as
a single global list of rules so it's
very simple to configure you can kind of
see everything in one list or one page
but in reality what we're doing is we're
taking those rules that you configure
and we're action
pushing them down and programming them
at the host level on the individual
machines where your virtual machines are
scheduled so really no equivalent from a
device perspective but we do kind of
manifest that in a way that's convenient
for you for both configuration and
management next is mapping for network
right so we have our physical network we
have virtual networks in our on-premise
environment what's the equivalent in
Google cloud and this is the VPC virtual
private cloud this is our global VPC and
it's really kind of the direct
correlation with your IP forwarding
domain on Prem a lot of customers have
just a single IP 40 domain which is you
have one routing space one IP space and
there's a lot of similarities between
that and the VPC in the cloud so for
example the IP addressing inside of a V
PC and inside one of your forwarding
domains on prim has to be unique right
you generally avoid duplicate IP
addressing likewise you don't generally
automatically connect to networks
together without some explicit
configuration so in your on-prem
environment you may establish
connections between networks you may
establish a BGP routing protocols
between networks to actually explicitly
make communication happen very similar
in the V PC environment right v pcs are
isolated and that they do not
communicate with other V pcs inside the
cloud unless you do something explicitly
to make that happen one interesting
thing about the V PC is it is a global
construct in Google cloud and what that
means is that the scope of the V PC how
big of a geographic area it actually
covers is completely dependent on how
you deploy workloads in the cloud so for
example if you start out by deploying
your workloads in one cloud region
that's really the scope of your V PC but
as soon as you start deploying workloads
and other cloud regions across the globe
the network scope immediately expands to
include that entire network and so this
is actually pretty unique to Google
cloud and it's actually a really really
nice implementation because it allows
you to basically instantly grow your
network in global scope kind of going
back to that global backbone slide that
I presented at the beginning with a
single routing and firewall policy so
your network your V RFS on-prem they map
into V pcs in the cloud environment
next we have the concept of VLANs so we
only use VLANs in a very limited fashion
in the cloud we don't use them actually
within the data center switching fabric
meaning you don't put your virtual
machines inside of a specific VLAN we
only use VLANs to actually virtualize
the connectivity back to your on-premise
environment this is specifically with a
product we have called cloud
interconnect that allows you to have
high speed low latency access from your
network to Google's network but you can
actually create multiple virtual links
across those physical circuits and
terminate those in different VP C's and
different locations across the world
that's it there's no VLANs anywhere else
in our environment there's an ovule and
numbering you need to think about making
sure that you put you know access
control or access lists and map
interfaces to a certain VLAN that just
doesn't exist in the cloud environment
today next we have subnets so show hands
who in the room remembers deploying
workloads in Google cloud before we had
V pcs and subnets anyone few people so
it's true that used to be one big flat
IP space across that entire global
backbone I mentioned but as customers
started connecting to our environment in
more different geographic locations we
needed the ability to provide them with
optimized access from a routing
perspective to the closest cloud region
where they're deploying workloads and
that's really the purpose of the subnet
inside of Google Cloud I would advise
you to think about it as less of an
isolation mechanism less of a
segmentation mechanism and more of an
identity regionally for instances that
you deploy in certain cloud regions so
for example you can deploy resources in
a cloud region on a single subnet so
long as that subnet is big enough from
an IP addressing perspective to handle
all of your workloads so all of your
kubernetes clusters all of your virtual
machines etc that's really the genesis
that's the primary purpose of subnets
they're really not intended to be kind
of a first-class entity to identify
systems
it's about efficient routing between
your environment and our environment so
your subnets they map into subnets and
Google cloud but the purpose of Google
cloud subnet is really about regional
identity or regional proximity of
resources
then we have IP addresses so our IP
addresses within your VP see their
regional constructs so you create a
subnet within a within a particular
region it has a unique set of IP
addresses for that region we also have
public IP addresses that are used for
our global load balancers that are
internet facing for the regional IP
addresses these are by default
automatically managed by the cloud so we
automatically allocate IP addresses to
machines we autoclave automatically
allocate IP addresses to kubernetes pods
etc so I want to actually ask you to do
something as you kind of go through this
session I want you to think about what
if you don't have the ability to
explicitly define the IP address for a
given virtual machine this is already
very common in kubernetes right you
can't specify that a kubernetes pod has
an explicit static IP address assume you
can't do that with a virtual machine how
are you gonna handle forwarding how are
you gonna handle access control
microsegmentation alright we're going to
talk about some of these things a little
bit later and finally the equivalent for
the firewalls in your environment or in
general access control we have a number
of products these are again globally
distributed and they really kind of span
layer 3 controls so building access
controls based on IP addressing all the
way up to layer 7 controls so does this
user who's part of this group have the
right access to actually interface with
this cloud API so there's a complete
spectrum of access controls that cover a
lot of different parts of the stack from
the network all the way up to the
application level so again this is
important when we start talking about
segmentation and the ability to kind of
abstract how we identify and control a
system separate from where it's actually
placed in the network and so with that
I'm gonna turn it over to Matt who's
going to talk about some common
enterprise design scenarios and how we
can approach those thank you very much
Zack I don't know how many of you are
public presenters but this is normally
the part where you get stuck looking
into the lights and forget everything
that you've prepared but what we really
wanted to talk about it this next stage
is how do we start mapping these analogs
into Google Cloud solutions specifically
so here you get a snapshot of what the
the Google cloud networking product
portfolio looks like today there's 20
plus products and services all focused
on
enabling your journey to the cloud we've
we've sort of grouped these into
different sections that represent the
way that customers are thinking about
the clouds so connecting scale optimized
security and modernize and so what we're
gonna do in this next section is we're
going to touch through a series of these
products and sort of answer questions
that customers come to us with so in
this section what we're going to focus
on are the cloud interconnected VPN and
V pcs so one of the first things that
customers think about when they're
coming to us is how do I take advantage
of this new network often times when you
have on-premise environments you have
fixed infrastructure in fixed locations
but you don't have the way a way to
extend your applications to where your
customers are improve the the speed and
latency and so that's where as Zack was
mentioning before global V PC comes into
play this is a way of simplifying the
ability to connect to all of the regions
where you deploy things makes it simple
for you to enable replication across
your applications as well as leveraging
Google manage services that are built
from the ground up on a globe or a multi
region deployment model and they
associated availability the next thing
once we've sort of started to map out
the network we've started to think about
well how do we fit this into our
operational model so bye-bye show of
hands how many of you no longer have
dedicated networking or security teams
so there's a few and we know the
industry is moving towards DevOps models
or dev sec ops models but until we we
sort of fully move into that we have to
think about how can we we take our
workflows in our on-premise environment
today and map those over to the cloud
this is where shared VPC comes into play
so shared VPC is designed around the
idea that we have different teams that
deploy our applications and different
teams that manage our networks and we
don't just want to give free rein to the
application teams to deploy networks as
they see fit we still want to have some
level of control so shared VPC is
enterprise friendly
it's a centralized model and it allows
you to centralize your administration
and auditability so now we've got a
global VP see we have a deployment model
that works as Zack mentioned before we
want to look at what I mean we're a
hybrid enterprise how are we going to
interconnect into GCP and it's important
to to note that you need different
models depending upon what you're going
to rely on that hybrid connectivity for
are you just doing management do you
need to do batch data loads at certain
times of day or is this going to become
a mission-critical part of the
application this is where things like
cloud VPN cloud interconnect come into
play and being able to map the your
requirements and your your cost to the
exact implementation so what does it
look like when we start to put these
things together this is an example a bit
of a zoomed in simplified example here
but starting on the left-hand side you
can see an on-premises network with four
dedicated interconnects connections
coming in to Google Cloud these are
coming into two separate regions that
are all are both accessible through the
global V PC that V PC is stored within a
shared V PC host project and we can
share individual subnets out to the
service projects so again it's a
relatively simple way of leveraging
physical connectivity ensuring a four 9s
SLA and giving you centralized
administration so from here one of the
other common questions that we get and I
was sort of confused when I first heard
this but there's some customers who are
surprised to hear that our managed
services are typically hosted on the
internet on external IPs now Zack and I
would probably be among the first to
argue that you know simply putting
something on a public IP really is about
accessibility and not security but for
customers that have invested in these
interconnects that want to leverage this
private connectivity for accessing and
managed services it makes sense to have
an option to do so and so that's where
we start to introduce private Google
access and private service access
so what these are are ways of extending
those managed services to your on-prem
environment so pause for just so could
as people take pictures but what it
really looks like is this so that same
interconnect model that you had before
what what you're now able to do is to as
a part of you are dynamic peering with
with with Hula's you're able to
advertise a restricted VIP back to your
on-premises environment so this is a
special IP range that will come from
your V PC to your on-premises
environment and then through the use of
DNS you can swing services over to that
restricted VIP the three basic models
for for using this are the first is to
do an enterprise-wide cname of start at
Google API comm to the restricted VIP if
you don't want this to apply to all of
your services what you may choose to do
is implement a DNS view so a view only
for certain clients implementing the
exact same redirection or you can even
implement it as a host based level so
we've talked about connectivity now I
want to spend just a few minutes on
security and most more specifically on
our cloud armor IIP vbc firewall rules
and cloud firewall rules so no one is
going to consider leveraging a cloud
service provider if they don't have
complete faith in the implementation of
firewalling GCP VPC firewalls provide a
microsegmentation model because they are
effectively implemented at the host
based level what that means is two
instances running on the same physical
host cannot connect to one another
without traversing that firewall and the
default stands for that firewall is a
deny ingress at the same time these
rules are stateful so they're simpler to
maintain than more traditional stateless
ACLs and we can see this segmentation
model implemented in the following slide
so again this is a relatively simplified
model here but when I started thinking
about this I have a question how many
people have had to implement 802 dot 1 X
in an on-premise environment
so there's a few people this is this was
pork based network access control so
this was introduced at a time when we no
longer knew what end point was going to
plug into what switch so we're in the
network they might be and be able to
dynamically configure that port with the
associated rules for that end point well
the same thing can be done with BBC
firewall rules you through the use of
tags or service accounts you can have
your endpoints inherit the rules that
they need in order to access the crutch
endpoints and you can do this all you
know very similar to 802 dot 1x but
without the pain of having to manage
tac-x so with this combination we have
granular rules that are applied
dynamically within our VPC and then as
we start to push out towards the edge we
have cloud armor and identity aware
proxy cloud armor will extend our
defense in depth strategy by adding
layer 7 DDoS and Web Application
Firewall and tore up our apps and IP
provides a way of extending our
applications to only specific users in
fact we also introduced quite recently a
blog post that talks about using IP in
place of Bastion hosts so now you can
open up 22 to your individual host that
you want to manage but ensure that's
only exposed through certain to certain
identities without the need of having a
separate management host then the next
part and this is a really critical one
because we've all heard repeatedly of
these stories about misconfigurations of
access rules on a managed service that
end up exposing data to unauthorized
clients so how you know how do we how do
we address this well Google is actually
taken a two-pronged approach to this the
first is a set of open source security
tools called for set E which give you
the ability to establish an inventory
policies and remediation actions
whenever changes are made within your
environment and the second is VPC
service controls which allows you to
establish a trusted perimeter model
around
VP sees and projects so this is what it
looks like in practice so here we have a
project of the VP C and the associated
services that we want to protect we also
through the same mechanism of the
private Google axis have the ability to
extend these services to our on-premise
environment and say that's a part of our
trusted perimeter
so when BBC Service controls is enabled
only resources from within the perimeter
can interact with those services and
they can't be used to copy those to any
external unauthorized projects and
prevent access from the Internet
so this protects against that Mis
configuration lastly all of these
security controls are great but
centralized logging and sim solutions
are not going away
so this is where VPC flow logs and
firewall logs come into play the VPC
flow logs provides you with net flow
style data TCP dump information without
the payload that gives you information
about the flows within your V PC
environment and firewall logs gives you
insight into what's being allowed and
blocked by your V PC firewalls so now
that you have a sense of the various
products the analogues to the on-prem
what the options are in in GCP what we
wanted to do was try something a little
different you know as now as Network
specialist Zack and I get the chance to
see many different customer
configurations and then this next
section we wanted to try and verbalize
the thought process that we go through
when considering different sets of
customer requirements before we start
that I just wanted to give you a few
quick points in terms of EPC design
pre-work and recommendations so the
first is identifying who your
stakeholders are this can vary depending
upon who you're trying to design this
VPC for is it for an individual
application align a business your entire
organization it's important to
understand who you're trying to address
and make sure that you really understand
their requirements the second is to
start with security objectives and not
security controls many times we see
customers
- - GCP and say how do I do X in GCP
rather than thinking about why they're
doing X so by starting with the security
objectives you have a very clear
understanding of what you're trying to
achieve and what your options are in the
cloud
the next is understanding how many V pcs
you're going to need and I don't mean
coming up with a static number like 5 6
7 10 the important thing here is to
understand what you're trying to achieve
where your scale and quota limits are
going to play and get an overall
understanding of what magnitude you're
gonna have to address and lastly think
simple don't design things just because
you can I mean we all know that
simplicity allows it's directly
correlated with support ability so
keeping it - exactly what you need is
going to be important if you wanted to
add on this slide I think the point of
number three is is relevant right it's
not a static number you're trying to get
it's really a pattern that you're trying
to use so that you can can grow and
scale your network environment inside
the cloud or the most efficient manner
possible yeah
so let's start with a simple scenario
here Zack like what do you see in this
in this in the show sure so again the
idea here is we're just this is kind of
basically our day job right so how do we
kind of think about the approaching this
out loud so obviously here I've got a
single V PC global pretty
straightforward looks like I have both
development and production workloads in
the same V PC they're across different
regions so they're in different subnets
single project which is also which is
also relevant when we look at how we
scale out and the other thing that's
apparent here is it looks to me like
this is predominantly a cloud isolated
workload right I don't see any hybrid
connectivity back to the on-premise
environment so those are kind of the
things that initially pop out at me any
any best practice you think we can take
away from this design yeah I mean I
think a couple here that really resonate
with me something you just mentioned
which is start out simple so I think
this is a very common approach that
customers who are either new to cloud
can take just so they kind of get their
bearings in the cloud environment
even customers that are coming from
other cloud providers and they're just
trying to get familiar and experience
with how some of our networking
constructs may different so for they
differ so for example the global V PC
how does it actually behave in practice
so simplicity is a key one here I think
the other one here too is just a small
number of subnets with larger address
ranges right there's no really reason to
kind of over rotate and start creating a
bunch of subnets within a region you can
start with one with adequate IP address
space we have a great feature where you
can actually grow the size of your
existing subnets and a completely
hitless manner to the vm's that are
already deployed this doesn't preclude
you from creating multiple subnets this
is just what we see and what we
recommend for customers who are just
getting started right one nice thing
here is that things are relatively
programmatic and easy to deploy and
manage inside of Google Cloud so even
four core infrastructure stuff that
takes a lot of planning and a lot of
effort to implement in an on-premise
environment they can actually be pretty
disposable and pretty easy to kind of
delete and recreate inside of the cloud
environment so I think overall a good
starting point one thing I do notice
here though right and I think a pretty
common recommendation as customers start
to scale in the cloud is really I'm kind
of starting to segregate or put more
kind of firm isolation between
development and production workloads so
you mean something that looks a little
more like this so in in this design
there's a couple of things that jump out
to me right away I mean that the first
is is exactly what you've sort of
identified there we've moved from a
subnet model as a isolation boundary
between our different environments and
into VPC level so at VPC level we've now
segregated firewall rule management into
two separate v pcs and then the other
big one that jumps out is the hybrid
connectivity so here we can see that
we've now deployed cloud routers
dedicated interconnect and VLAN
attachments into each of the individual
V pcs yeah I mean just a point kind of
on the hybrid connectivity right if you
notice here we have actually separate
connectivity coming from on-premise into
each V PC right and this is virtual
connectivity so if you're using VPN for
example these
separate VPN tunnels if you're using
interconnect this can be the same
physical circuit that you peer with
Google Network Google's network on but
different logical connections those
interconnect attachments I mentioned
previously that terminate in the
separate projects right so you kind of
extend the isolation of the different
environments
all the way through the connectivity
back to your on-premise environment
right so it's really really cleans kind
of separation which works well and as
you've mentioned in previous slides
because we now have separate independent
V pcs and there is no inherent
connectivity between them we need to
start thinking about where how is our
application deployment look where our
build servers where we actually
deploying from for deploying from
on-premise this works
we've got connectivity between them but
if the build servers are sitting in one
of those V pcs we now have to start to
look at vbc peering or connecting those
V pcs together in order to allow for
that build process for that deploy
process to succeed and when we start to
think about those those peering that's
when we need to start thinking about
well what are the aggregate resource
requirements when we mesh these two v
pcs together so when you when you you
think about this design what's the next
sort of logical extension where do
people go from here especially if we
wanted to sort of aligned with that
workflow framework from earlier yeah so
one thing I noticed when Matt asked who
doesn't have network or security teams
anymore there was like a few hands and
so if I assume the inverse I assume that
most of you still do and so one thing
that we see if we can go to the next
slide is this concept of shared V PC
that Matt talked about and so to me
shared V PC is as much an organizational
construct as it is a set of technologies
that you leverage in the cloud and what
I mean by that is that shared V PC is
designed for organizations where you
want to maintain centralized
administration and control of the
network and the security functions in
the cloud and so shared V PC does that
shared V PC is still fundamentally a
single V PC but it's a single V PC that
can be leveraged by multiple projects
and it has a curated set of permissions
of iam permissions so there's a specific
role for network admins in the shared V
PC and they control as you might imagine
creating subnets establishing hybrid
connectivity establishing routing
policies there is an explicit role for
security
admins in the shared VPC model who
control firewall rules etc so if your
organization is structured in that way
and that's an organizational construct
you intend to carry over into the cloud
the shared VPC is a really nice model
for this so here you can see we've got a
couple of things in play here we've got
actually multiple different VP C's all
still within a single project and in the
shared VPC model we call this a host
project so your host project has all of
your networking and security stuff the
VP C the firewall rules the connectivity
back to your on-premise environments and
then you have one or more service
projects service projects are separate
projects they're usually given to the
application or development teams in
those separate projects they can spin up
their own compute they can spin up their
own kubernetes clusters they have the
autonomy to manage their workloads
themselves and these service projects
attach to the shared V PC to leverage
those resources so the networking and
security teams maintain control over the
network and security the application
teams they manage their workloads they
manage compute they manage kubernetes
clusters etc see I mean you know in
terms of best practices right just think
kind of thinking about this a little bit
you know number one is I like simplicity
right so we got it's still pretty simple
model it's still the single V PC kind of
model if you will which again kind of
just reinforces the point that we want
to kind of start to think about non
networking constructs as the primary
identifier for workloads right so we
don't want just the fact that you happen
to be connected to a V PC to say
everything about what you can do right
there's there's a better way to address
that which we're going to talk about a
little bit another nice thing about
shared V PC is you actually have pretty
granular control on which portions of
the V PC are visible to the service
projects so for example you can say you
know this particular group of service
projects for you know service XYZ they
can only see this particular subnet or
set of subnets in the V PC right so you
can kind of help people not make
mistakes in terms of deploying their
workloads in the wrong location so this
works really well it's actually a very
common thing it's pretty popular with
enterprise customers mostly as I
mentioned because of that organizational
alignment
but question I guess back for you is
what if you need to kind of scale this
out right because fundamentally we're
dealing with a single V PC what if
things go really well and you need to
kind of scale up to maybe you know tens
of thousands of virtual machine
instances yeah so I think that's when we
start to see a move towards this model
where now we are separating out the
hosts projects and going with a single V
PC per host project this allows us to
more accurately align V PC and project
quotas to an individual host project and
allow them to scale independently of one
another so no longer are you going to be
worried about you know if a dev resource
spins up things that you're prod project
relies upon because now they're managed
independently the other big thing that
this design starts to introduce is
segregation at the I am level so in the
previous models when you're using the
security admin role within that V PC or
that that host project you would have
had the ability to modify firewall rules
across any of the V pcs in this model
they're now independent of one another
so we can have different users mapped to
each of those host projects and we're
starting to see a scale out pattern here
you know what what we're talking about
is you know building that that host
project segregation at the environment
level so prod tests death but we could
continue to make this more granular if
our application requirements demanded
where we can create host projects on
individual line of business or
application so just some clear I just
make sure I understood one thing you
said so there's segregation of the I n
permission that's because the
permissions are associated at the
project level right okay so by moving
into separate projects here you're
giving the ability to kind of delegate
administration to different parts of the
cloud environment that's right as we
continue to move out in this scale model
what you can see is now we are
increasing the number of cloud routers
increasing the number of VLAN
attachments and while it's a
software-defined network on the Google
cloud side on the on-premise side we
need to think about how we're going to
be managing those those connections so
you know what if it's what if it's a
pain on the on-premise side what can we
do to help optimize for that yeah it's a
great question and it's a frequent
feedback we hear from customers it's
like it's great
network and the cloud is Software
Defined I can spin things up and delete
things with relative ease but when it
starts to talk about hybrid
interconnectivity with your on-premise
environment that may not always be the
case right so getting the appropriate
permissions to change configuration add
additional interfaces create new BGP
peers sometimes customers want to avoid
this and what they're really after
basically is trying to leverage not only
the same physical connectivity with the
Google cloud network but the same
logical or virtual connections with the
Google cloud network and so we move on
to a different scenario here which the
actual VPC structure here which you know
dev tests and prod in multiple projects
that really stays the same the one big
difference here is we've actually
leveraged another VPC that were terming
here in this presentation a connectivity
VPC now this is not a separate type of
VPC that you check a box and say I want
this to be connectivity this just
happens to be a normal DPC that we're
using in a very specific way so what
we've actually done here is we're
actually moving all of the hybrid
connectivity out of the individual
environment based projects and we're
putting that into this connectivity VPC
and then we peer the connectivity VPC
with all of those environment based
projects so this actually relies on a
feature that we've just recently
released called VPC peering custom
routes that allows us to propagate
routes that are learned dynamically from
your on-premise environment across VPC
peering relationships so the routes that
you advertise into the Google cloud
environment that specify what networks
in your on-prem environment are going to
be reachable from the cloud we can now
propagate those routes all the way down
to these environment based
epcs so pretty pretty powerful
capability nice way to not only leverage
the same physical connectivity but to
really remove a lot of the kind of
hybrid connectivity constructs out of
those environment VP sees another common
thing I see as customers grow a lot of
customers especially larger enterprises
they may have multiple business units or
business entities inside the
organization and those entities pretty
much want to operate autonomously within
the cloud except when it comes to paying
for hybrid connectivity right they
almost always want to share that right
so I'm going to use the same kind of
high speed connections I have to the
Google cloud environment even though I
may be an entirely different business
and
so where we have this segregation here
by environment type like dev test and
production you could also think about
that to be separate logical business
entities or small peered groups of VP
C's for a particular business entity
name and whatever you want and
inevitably in that case there's almost
always services that you want to share
across those business groups right
whether it's Active Directory or source
code repositories or the CIC D pipeline
those resources are also a good fit for
this connectivity V PC because it has
peered access to all of those downstream
V pcs as well
so this access again this is really just
about how you use the networking
constructs in the cloud versus just
going and saying this is gonna be like a
connectivity V PC
the scope and use of the V PC really
defined its purpose inside of the cloud
environment so it's not like you're
limited to a single connectivity V PC
this is actually a scale out pattern
yeah you could you can scale that out
I'm working with one customer now where
they have 13 independent business
entities inside of their organization
each one has their own kind of
connectivity V PC if you will and then
they have a set of small group of
downstream V pcs that are environmental
ID right so dev stage production etc so
I think are we kind of we have one more
right which is one more so I think maybe
we'll do a little curveball here just
thinking about what customers commonly
kind of come to us with I'm gonna give
this one to you just because I can so
what if a customer needs to bring kind
of a third party Network capability or
device into the cloud it's a virtual
machine why would you ever need that oh
man you know just you know just to say
it's needed right how would you how
would that influence and change the way
you're doing V PC design and some of the
things that we've talked about so I mean
wouldn't it be nice if if there were
cloud native solutions for everything we
wanted but I mean the reality is that
for any number of reasons there are
gonna be times when you need to bring
appliances into the cloud you need to
start to think about what those
deployment models look like now the
icons are a little small at this point
cuz we're starting to group these things
together but what what we wanted to sort
of call out here is the idea that
typically these devices are require
multi NICs so you can you can think of
an ng fw that you wanted to do layer
seven inspection on or something that's
going to act as a router between your
various V pcs but there are there are
specific rules within GC p that actually
requires to modify the the V PC design
so here what what you're seeing is that
multi NIC requires different V pcs for
each of the of the interface cards and
all of those V pcs have to be in the
same project so sorry Matt just one
second so when you say multi NIC devices
you're talking about like a virtual
appliance or security vendor or
something says multiple interfaces
exactly yeah
so the the best practices the things you
need they the considerations you need to
bring into play when you're thinking
about these devices though is how are
you routing traffic to those devices are
you modifying the default route what are
the implications to accessing manage
services when you're no longer using the
default internet gateway instead using a
third-party device as well as thinking
about high availability so how is this
how are you ensuring that this device is
up and forwarding packets how do you
help check it each one of these are
important considerations but there is a
deployment pattern for using these
devices within GCP good stuff so I think
we've covered a number of different
scenarios right I think this is pretty
commonly what we see from customers in
terms of how they start their journey
really specific to networking inside the
cloud again the premise here right is
just start simple it's easy to kind of
expand and evolve over time as your
requirements your need change in the
clay in the cloud environment right
there's no reason to kind of overly kind
of engineer from a design perspective
also think less about the traditional
networking constructs like placement in
the network and IP addresses and subnet
membership is really the kind of primary
identifier of a particular workload
right as as Matt mentioned right we have
capabilities within the firewall to do
micro segmentation that can actually
follow a particular virtual machine
instance or kubernetes pod regardless of
where it happens to be instantiated in
the network right so this makes actually
creating the policies and maintaining
those policies inside of our environment
much much more simple by leveraging
these kind of
distractions for identity and so I think
that what do we have any we have
something else right you you have one
something else do you want to talk about
so I almost wish I had a black
turtleneck on for this part you know as
much as Zach and I would like to think
that you know forty minute presentation
on some example V PC deployment
scenarios would be enough for for you to
sort of rethink your designs we actually
have gone one step further so we believe
that as a cloud service provider the
obligation is on us to provide best
practices for these things and you would
have seen as we were going through these
these deployments that we had different
sets of best practices that go down the
side so I am very pleased to announce
during this session that we have just
made live our V PC best practices and
design guide so the links that you see
up here are links to all the things that
we think are important when first moving
into your V PC design decision so we
want you to start by thinking about your
organization your line of business your
project where what are you trying to
design for and then use these links so
bittley's slash net 201 - V PC for our V
PC best practices guide net 201 - ent
for best practices for enterprise
organizations net 201 policy for
understanding I am policy design as it
applies to enterprise customers you may
have also noticed in the past few months
we launched a new Coursera course for
networking in the Google cloud platform
we encourage you to to use that if you
want to continue to get your hands dirty
understand how these different
components work together and then get
started today
build something understand that this V
PC design that you implement now uses
all the information that you have
available to you but it may not apply in
the future there may be iterations and
that's okay
and lastly showcase your skills so we
also another thing that we've worked on
in the last few months is to launch the
Google certified professional network
engineer and I've been told there's some
pretty cool swag if you decide to to go
right the test either today or in the
future additionally we have a special
guest with us today who's actually the
author of the BBC best practices Mike
Columbus who will be signing autographs
officials over there in the audience if
anyone wants to talk to him but also
Matt didn't you you also worked on the
certification I so yeah perfect so one
more slide again the door is open it
will stay open through April 25th as we
mentioned please please add your
questions there now or in the future we
really look forward to engaging with you
online and take the survey right let us
know how we did let us know what things
you want to hear about in the future
whether it's in print online whether
it's in future next sessions we really
really appreciate you taking the time to
come to our session and we hope you
enjoyed the rest of your weekend next
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]